infections have been recorded in six of  Syria's 14 governorates mostly in Aleppo  a source from this Hospital says more  than 4 000 people have been treated here  in the past three weeks  the UN says the war has caused extensive  damage to water pipes and more than half  the healthcare facilities aren't  functioning  in the past you know we used to have at  least the basic infrastructure there  like for example getting you know clean  sources of water and the sewage system  is there almost you know to deal with  this sort of challenges but now this you  know 12 years of war led into  destruction of the infrastructure  the who sent two plane loads of Aid to  the region and its training aid groups  but it's concerned about those already  vulnerable to disease and hunger  for the hundreds of thousands of  displaced syrians living in camps a  fresh outbreak of Cholera threatens  further misery in the months ahead  Laura butter manly Al Jazeera